started to put it in hasn't scored since
Midway through the third Denwood he
gives it right back shooter on Downton
three-pointer on its way for the top
it's good Luca don't change a clutch
three
timeout Lakers decided not to double
dodge it like they have been the whole
second half to not open up other people
but that gives Dodgers a chance hadn't
had a bucket since the 522 Mark of the
third quarter
o'clock to nine dinwiddy's got he's got
Gabriel on
trying to get
okay
Spencer Dinwiddie
three to shoot Dodge it try to get some
Loom three-pointer he's good Luca don't
change sticks and get James against
doncic here for the last shot James gets
by him LeBron with the reverse blocked
by wood and Dodson comes away from the
pack and just so for entertainment
purposes it looked like James just lost
the handle on his way up they might
credit wood for a block there saying I
was
throws another one down
[Applause]
Westbrook and it's denied by wood
he came down and rolled his ankle out of
the play right now and it's still ready
James oh what a passing Gabriel a
two-handed flush
Lucas to the Finish Line a hard-fought
Dallas win what a grinder tonight in two
overtimes James and doncic with an
Embrace great performances by each
LeBron with 24 and 16